[Music]
these are wondering how Victoria Beckham
always looks so magnificent well I found
out her fashion and beauty tips when
Victoria debuted her latest clothing
collection
[Music]
it's very difficult to find the perfect
nude lip some have said I'm obsessed
with nudes
noodling there won't be some other nudes
- but that's not for today just my
husband um the starting point is a
powerful oil mask my skin perfecting
powder the 43 year old working mama for
often posts makeup and beauty tips from
her new Estee Lauder collection she eats
salmon and takes bee pollen every day
and when it comes to fashion Victoria
proves sometimes less is more like these
jeans and simple solid colored shirt
fashions sometimes can be sort of less
friendly in some ways and I feel like
you're like everyone take my secrets I
love that about you 100% I'm not quite
as grumpy as I look I mean I've said
that for many years you you still have
an insecurity are there think times
where you go all Victoria I look in the
mirror and all I don't like this I don't
like that but I think the older that you
get the more accepting you become this
is me I'm gonna make the best of what
I've got I'm gonna be healthy I'm going
to work out I'm gonna eat properly and
healthily you know and drink lots of
water sleep as much as I can and after
that it is what it is there's just your
face there's nothing else I can do the
Beckham boys were front row is Victoria
debuted her 2018 spring line call it
power dressing with a feminine touch
oversized Blazers with pockets big
enough to fit your clutch and this red
sparkly flat is a secret shout-out to
daughter Harper I was on skype with
Harper the other day
and I said you know Harper look at this
shoe that mummys made for her show and
she just said
I need that shoe mummy I really really
need that shoe you know fashion should
be fun and it's about finding new ways
of wearing things I think people on
their bad day would like to wake up and
look like Victoria Beckham she's
fabulous
and the collection was beautiful
[Music]
you